Can we even close? So, um, yeah dude, you know, what's coming out, you know,
what's coming up this week, you know, it's coming up this week, man,
Halloween Halloween. Or if you're a, you can be like all Hallows' Eve.
You know what I mean? Um,
so Halloween is coming up and I know we talked about this because we've had
Halloween shows before at the, um, at the congratulations and.
Cause we've been doing this podcast for about three years, but uh,
let's just send out some reminders, man. Hey chicks. And also.
Um, Halloween is one day, not nine days.
So you celebrate on the day and that's it.
You don't celebrate seven weeks early, dude. I mean,
I swear to God people started celebrating an August man.
I was out by the way,
my friends friend had an outfit on. I thought he was dry.
I thought he was dressed for Halloween. And you wasn't. He was just wearing, he,
he was just fashionable. Quote, unquote got mad, got mad. I was like,
it's a little early from the dress of Halloween.
Found out that that's his actual outfit got mad, got mad.
It's all good.
But I got mad where the mostly the regular,
if you want to get crazy and put one scarf on or wear sunglasses
as the sun goes down fine,
but don't get crazy at nighttime. If you're wearing sunglasses, sunglasses,
be blind, be blind.
I make fun of nobody who wears sunglasses at night. Do you know why?
Because it's not fair because they're blind and that's it.
There are no exceptions. If you're wearing sunglasses at night,
you get extra rights. You're blind. Okay.
Um, yeah. So, uh, you know,
it's like Kanye is bringing back the baggy jeans getting all. It's all good man.
Baggy jeans. No, I baggy jeans, man. Remember baggy jeans.
Remember you used to wear baggy jeans.
Remember James VanDerBeek and varsity blues.
When he's leaning up against the wall talking to the chick and then it cuts to
the wide shot and you're like, does he have another,
does he have the rest of Dawson's Creek in his legs? Dude,
James VanDerBeek.
No.
Have a little bit more tight pants.
I remember I would wear tight shirts and my uncle would be like,
that shirt doesn't fit. And I was like, yeah, it does. Anyway.
That's a regular story. But um, yeah,
so I was just, you know,
fashion is always going to be like, it's, it's like cutting edge until like,
you're like, it's like annoying until it's cutting edge. And then you're like,
okay, cool. But I swear to God, I don't want to die.
I don't want to have to wear baggy jeans again, dude.
It'll end up happening, dude. I'm going to have the baggiest jeans.
I.
Um, so I, um, I'm gonna have the bag jeans. I'm all the way to Kevin Smith.
Uh, so, but Halloween's coming up Halloween dude chicks.
Can't wait for it to be Halloween. I was thinking about this man.
I was like thinking about like, you know,
cause I see on like Instagram going out to like I see on
Instagram, like, you know,
my friend was showing me this chick story and she was with like nine other
chicks and they were all dressed like straight up hookers
dude. Here's the thing, man. I know this is like a hack premise,
but like if you dress up as a thing for Halloween,
you're a. Yeah. all good.
Yeah. E if the only thing over your neck,
apples are like leaves and you're like, yeah, but I'm poison Ivy. Great.
How much is it?
You know dude. Oh, you're a sexy mailman. All good.
You're a sexy male woman. Oh, you're a sexy dog. Catcher. All good.
How much?
How much is it for a second dude?
You know, just relax. Relax.
Halloween is all good.
Put on a ups outfit button. This up.
Stop showing cleavage,
relax IES a lot. You know,
if, if not fine,
but how much it's all good.
But you start unbuttoning that ups outfit, how much?
Hundred, 4,000 you high class,
you know? Oh, you're a,
you know, Pillsbury Doughboy with a skirt on all good.
How many stacks?
And by the way, it's Monday.
Uh, it's all good. But remember it here. Remember who said it? Crystal?
Leah said it either hookin,
you know, or the guy that's like,
how annoying is this out? How annoying is this outfit?
The guy who works out a lot and just takes
off his shirt and paints his body green. And he goes as the Hulk, Hey man,
you're making everybody green at the party.
You're rubbing up against hookers, making them green. Dude.
I have stacks for the slutty ups girl. And now she's guy.
I,
I should get half off if the ups sexy is now a
little bit green because of the pay for this, bro. Hey, Hey,
ho you paying for this.
You know how, how
work guy is it to go as like a wrestler? You know,
I'm Hollywood hall collagen. I got a blonde mustache and I'm beefy,
dude. I just don't get, like, if you re,
if you're a dad and you raised a girl and,
and like,
she's like gets to the age where whatever she's
18, 19, I don't know when it starts. But like,
and then she's just all of a sudden you she's like, Hey dad,
check out my Halloween costume from and she's at in college.
And she sends you like, look, look,
I'm, you know, I'm a Teletubby but the,
but the parts are cut out instead of the little television that they have.
It's just her are out.
Why do your have to be out? What, what chick wants?
What I want to know is what Eric wants more attention from guys.
I want to know what girl wants more attention from
guys. All you have to do to get attention from guys is go into
Starbucks.
All you gotta do is walk into home Depot,
shortened it home Depot,
all you gotta do is walk into a high hop and
your gonna be a, you know,
ups check for Halloween for all Hallows' Eve. Hey,
no, I'll hookers Eve. That's what it is. All hookers Eve.
And then the guy who's the Hulk and his green makeup is smearing all
over his shoulder and he's getting it on your girl.
And you're like, dude, you're going to pay. You're going to buy her drinks. Nah,
bro. I'm just a Hawk man. Like I just don't get Halloween,
man. You're 23 Chu dune.
Ah, boy, I just don't. I don't, you know the guy to,
Hey man, I'm risky business. Um,
I got a leather jacket on and no pants lock 'em up
legal, illegal. Luckily give him up, dude.
Hey I'm out guy. Lock them up, dude.
Ho how awful our costumes for real,
like what if like for real,
those were the costumes that they used in movies and like, and like that.
Like if the X men weren't done by like, like costume designers,
they were done by like people who got drunk on Halloween.
That movie would rep dude I'd watch that. Like if they made a movie,
if they made the movie like dark Phoenix and they were, and they were like,
legitimately, like, it was just like Nikki's outfit. She's like,
I'm done Phoenix. I'm dark Phoenix.
And she's the girl I'm dark Phoenix
I'm man. And then it was her saving the world
and some guy's Colossus and he's just all painted silver and he's got it in his
eyes a little bit and he keeps rubbing his eyes cause it's up his contact.
And then at the end of the movie, by the end of the movie,
dark Phoenix is a little silver too. Cause he keeps touching her ah,
dude, how many people are dressing up as Billie Eilish to it.
I love that. How fit that,
where people think they're going to be clever and then they,
and then they go get to the party and there's like seven other Billie Eilish is.
And they're like, Oh, I thought it was clever.
And are they in the exact same outfit of the picture that they Googled as
someone else? Even though Billie Eilish wears like 75 different outfits,
they pick the one that's popular on Google and they see someone else and they're
like, Oh. And they have to pretend they're friends with her. Or like,
how about this? How many sexy jokers are there going to be in like a
cropped, you know, a purple suit.
Oh, you know what? The worst outfits are.
People who think they're funny with the meme costumes when they're like,
when they're they're like they have to hold something, dude, if you're,
if your costume involves you holding something to stand next to it,
go yourself. Huh?
Like the meme, the why though meme or,
or you have to do a move. So people get the costume, you know like this,
this beam, somebody, I saw somebody dressed up as the,
the lady who goes like this, the, the, the lady who's like this,
like with her hands on her knees. And like, you're like, who are you dressed as?
And the guy's like, hold on a second. And then he gets on his,
he puts his hands on his knees and you're like, Oh,
you're that idiot meme thing.
Care's the best thing you can do the best actually
you can get on Halloween from your costume. Is this Oh,
bro. That's the worst, best reaction.
Do you understand?
Oh, look, the guy's dressed up as a Freudian slip.
He's on a slip and it says Freud on his chest. Uh, anyway,
let's get drunk.
The meme based Halloween costumes, you know,
the guy dressed up as you know, I had to do it to them guy. Hey guy,
you just looked like a date rapist. Um,
wow dude, I look gray as today. It's all good man. Due to my pasty white.
Yup. Does it matter? Nope. Does life still rip? Eh, yes dude.
Yeah man. Life rips. You know what I'm being for? Halloween pasty.
That's it I'll put on a shirt. Maybe I'll put on some special pants,
but pasty guy.
How about the thing that goes like this on Halloween ever if you're somewhere,
if you're somewhere in Halloween during Halloween the day and you can't
hear this.
[Inaudible].
You're in a basement far underground or you're in the middle of the
rain forest because every like 19th house
thinks it's like, why is that a thing? That's nothing.
That's not even a noise that is made ever anywhere.
But on Halloween, it's not a ghost.
You hear ghost. If you Google ghost and you here, you, you, you, you put a,
uh, thing on YouTube, the boosts, the ghosts of go, Ooh.
Or if you Google for real ghosts, the best you'll hear is this.
You know what I mean? I love that. When you're watching you're there.
If you're there to speak, speak to us.
If there are say something we're friendly, we come in peace.
Cheer that who's, that.
I don't know. I got real cold. All of a sudden you feel that cold.
Then it cuts a talking head. And he's just like, I got to tell you, man,
I never felt so cold in my life. It was just like a gust.
It was like all of a sudden I was in the Arctic cuts back. You're there.
Roger, if you're there, say something, give us something,
Oh. It's cold. It got cold. Did you feel that?
And then it'll be like the EKG and the like, play it back and I'll be like,
Oh, did you hear that? Cross? Play it back.
And then he was like, it cuts the target. He's like, he very clear.
He said full grass. He very clearly said far Gras. Cause that's what he ate.
That was his last meal before, uh,
that was his last meal before he was on death row for fraud,
make a noise. It's just a pipe. You know,
it's a pipe clanking it's house noises.
Anyway.
Is like what.
Decided that was going to be the noise for Halloween.
I'm unplugging all that when I get there. And then there's always that, ah, ha.
Uh, ha.
Scary. Just a creaky door is WD 40.
I'm walking around with WD 40 on Halloween and my unplugging hand.
And when I get to a place where I hear cricket doors,
I just sprayed in the people's faces and then unplug with the other hand,
I unplugged the, what is that thing even called? Hey,
do you have that thing? You go to the Halloween stores, bro.
There's so much weirdness about Halloween. You know,
like Halloween stores, you can just go to a Halloween store and it like opens in
September and then just closes November 1st.
And there are 45 of them in Burbank, California.
You know, they just opened in September and then,
and then come November 1st,
literally shut the down until next September. Like,
Hey,
how do you stay in business? All good.
How do you stay in bed?
Is what I want to know is how do you sell enough?
which masks and.
Machines.
From September 20th to October 30th
to stay in business when there's Amazon.
So weird that Halloween stores are a thing.
I would walk by one all the time when I was in NYU. And I would just be like,
how's this thing. Stay in business.
And they'd have the same costumes in the windows in March.
I was like a werewolf. So weird.
Here we go. Add to my baby.